قبيله بدء حرب اوكرانيا اعلن البيت الابيض
ان الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدر وافق مبدئيا
على لقاء نظيره روسيف لاديمير بوتين لبحث
الازمه الاوكرانيه شرطه لا تشرع روسيا في
عمل عسكري بعد بدء الحرب انقطعت الاتصالات
حتى منتصف ايار مايو عندما اجرى وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرشويكو الامريكي لويد
اوستن محادثه هاتفيه للمره الاولى اكد
خلال لها ضروره الحفاظ على قنوات اتصال
مفتوحه بين الجانبين لاحقا في شهر يوليو
الخارجيه
محادثه هاتفيه هي الاولى بينهما منذ بدا
الحرب وقلب لينكن انه حتى على قبول عرض
واشنطن للافراج عن الامريكيين معتقلين في
روسيا وفي الثامنه عشر من نوفمبر قال
سيرجيريا كوف نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ان موسكو مستعده لعقد حوار رفيع المستوى
مع الولايات المتحده بشان الاستقرار
الاستراتيجي اذا كانت واشنطن مستعده لذلك
ولكن دون مناقشه اي شيء متعلق باوكرانيا
وفي التاسعه والعشرين من الشهرين نفسه كان
مقررا ان يلتقي مسؤولون روسول وامريكيون
في العاصمه المصريه لمناقشه استئناف
عمليات تفتيش بموجب معاهده يوستارت للحد
من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه لكن اللقاء
تاجل
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون في واشنطن في اول ايام
شهر ديسمبر قال رئيس الامريكي جو بيدا انه
مستعدون للحديث مع نظيره الروسي اذا اظهر
بوتين رغبه في انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
وفي السابع من الشهرين نفسه هجره الولايات
المتحده وروسيا عمليه تبادل سجناء شملت
اطلاق سراح لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه
بريتنير مقابل اطلاق سراح فيكتور بوت احد
اشهر تجار الاسلحه الروس وفي التاسع من
ديسمبر قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
نادي دبلوماسيين روسيا وامريكيين عقدوا
مباحثات في اسطنبول خشتي ما وصفها بالامور
المثيره للقلق في العلاقات الثنائيه